は）ある日、僕とトミック君は海へ出かけていた
ただの散歩のように見えるが
まあ　いつも通り
ドッキリです
ト)トミトミJだよー　そして
は)こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーです
ト)今日は何をってかこぅ
ト)何を撮るんだい？
は)今日はですねとある情報を聞きまして
は)僕が住む静岡の海に
は)めっちゃ高値で買える
ト)すごいこれやらせじゃない？
は)ガチです　ガチです
は)何か情報があったんですよ
ト)なんかそれやらせくさいんだけど
は)ホントっすよ
は)何とか石っていう
は)黄緑っぽいあれがあって
は)すごいこう
は)青色い石があるらしいんすよ
は)それをちょっと一緒に探しに行きましょう　ト)OK
は)ホントにありますよ
ト)ホントだぁ～
は)とりあえずここら辺で情報聞きますか
は)あお願いします
は)はい～というわけでここら辺という情報という情報を聞いたんですけども
は)これどうすか？絶対違いますよね？
ト)150％違うでしょ
ト)こんなぁ整備されてたら
ト)普通石見つからないだろ
は)まあ　確かにそうですね
は)いや　海沿いかもしんないす　逆に
は)ちょ　戻りましょ
ト)嘘でしょ
は)そんなこと喋る？
は)ホントですよ
は)ありますよ
ヤ)おい
は)この人悪くないんです
ヤ)どーすんだよ
は)ちくしょーーーーー
は)トミックさんがヤンキーにぶつかって
は)ヤンキーの大事そうなツボが壊れたら
ト)ツボじゃないじゃん
は)骨董品が壊れたら
は)どう反応するか
ト)どう反応するかって
ト)ちょっと不自然すぎだよ
は)ちょっと無理があったね
は)いやぁ　ちょっと難しかったす今回は
は)はい　という訳で今回の企画は
は)失敗ということで
は)また次回リベンジさせてください
ト)あの　これリベンジもくそもないからね